Speaker 1: this you have to see Pakistan has
this foreign minister named Shah Mahmood Qureshi.
And this guy doesn't even try to hide anti-Semitic
slurs with the coded language and sophisticated
analogies and metaphors that some try to use
to hide their anti-Semitic slurs.
He just drops an anti-Semitic slur that Jews
control the media during the first 15 seconds
of an interview with CNN Bianna Golodryga.
And you just have to see this now, sadly,
and we'll talk about this more later this
week.
There has been an explosion of anti-Semitic
violence around the US in the last few days
since the Israeli Gaza cease fire.
There are random Jewish people being attacked
and beaten across the US, incidents being
investigated in Los Angeles and New York and
in many other places, people being punched,
kicked, beaten.
It's insane.
We're going, what's going on?
We're seeing it on our channel where we're
having to ban at this point, it's hundreds
of people per day.
It's never been this bad, it's it's been bad,
it's never been as bad as in the last week
anti-Semitic comments, and we're just banning,
banning, banning people on YouTube, Twitch,
Facebook, Reddit, Twitter, et cetera, et cetera.
But this isn't random.
People like I expect to get emails about Jews
control the media, you know, from Bob in West
Virginia.
But this is the Pakistani foreign minister
using this line.
So let's jump into it.
This interview taking place right before the
Israeli Gazan cease fire was announced.
Take a look.
Speaker 3: And the Pakistani foreign minister
joins me now from New York.
Mr. Minister, thank you so much for joining
us.
It has been a very busy day from your end.
Do you hear any talks about a possible cease
fire coming anytime soon?
Speaker 4: I am convinced the tide is turning.
I am convinced the public pressure, the pressure
of public opinion is mounting on cease fire
is inevitable.
Israel is losing out there, losing the media
war.
Despite their connections, they are losing
the media war.
The tighter there
Speaker 3: is, their connections,
Speaker 4: deep pockets.
What does that mean for the very influential
people?
I mean, the controlled media.
Speaker 3: I mean, I would call that an anti-Semitic
remark.
Speaker 4: Well, you see, the point is they
have a lot of influence and they get a lot
of coverage.
Now, what is balanced, that is the citizen
journalist,
Speaker 1: their connections, deep pockets,
they control the media.
I have to commend Bianna Golodryga because
she did something that lots of people won't
do, which is just straight up call it what
it is, which is anti-Semitic.
There's often mincing words where the purveyor
of this stuff will use coded language.
And then the person doing the interview also
will use coded language or mince words in
some way.
He goes headfirst, dove right into it.
Jews control the media with money and influence.
And she says that's an anti-Semitic comment.
And the foreign minister is sort of unsure
how to respond.
And he kind of drifts into something else
and says, well, let me say this other thing
now.
What's really nuts?
And this is.
This I don't even know what to what to call
this, if you look online at articles and segments
about this segment.
It is riddled with even more anti-Semitic
comments saying good for the finance minister
for calling out Jewish control of media.
There's a huge contingent and sadly, many
are on the American left who loved what the
foreign minister said.
It's sad, but it's seen as more acceptable
to be openly anti-Semitic at this time because
of the Israeli-Palestinian situation, which,
of course, relates to Israeli foreign policy,
which I find terrible.
Right.
And I've called out.
How long have I been against Israeli foreign
policy and the Netanyahu administration?
I don't know.
And the reason that there's general anti-Semitism
towards random global Jews is because of the
anti-Semitic trope that any Jewish person
around the world holds a dual loyalty to Israel.
And we've talked about that many times before.
Now, by the way, Pakistani Twitter was cheering
this as if the finance minister, the foreign
minister, did the most heroic thing anybody
could have done, finally putting the Jews
in their place for control of media as if
it's a new and unstated truth that he's finally
willing to say.
Pakistani Twitter users have been calling
the finance minister courageous, brave, wise.
It is jarring.
It's not altogether surprising.
I saw one nice response to this clip, which
was an image of pictures of Jewish elected
officials with stars of David, American elected
officials with stars of David identifying
them as Jewish.
It was a really nice touch, you can imagine.
So anyway, nice job by Bianna Golodryga.
She's getting absolutely destroyed for this
by Pakistani Twitter and by others.
It's all become quite more brazen lately.
I don't remember it ever being as bad as in
the last week that we we don't have enough
moderators on any of our platforms to actually
keep up with the anti-Semitism that has exploded
here.
And we'll have a little more about this on
the show's Instagram.
Make sure you're following following us there
at David Pakman show and follow me on Instagram
at David Pakman.
We'll take a quick break.
Next, there's somebody now you might be able
to guess who is proposing a real insurrection,
not like the one from January six.
That's after the break